[Music]
in too soon news submitted by California
love exactly doctor brain is life I know
[Laughter]
what mean to you all day I'm sorry
Martin I'm sorry you could snap your
spine in half you're picking on the
buffest guy in the room I know are you
so cute adorable I am thank you
he really is people are divided on louis
c.k making a stand-up come back people
are comedians people and commute I mean
comedians are people too
I'm 4head making a comeback because he's
easily on my top ten favorite stand-up
comedians I love them I think I think
it's I would actually like think it's
harder to come back and I think it's
easy to just give up because of a
mistake yeah I'm for it also I read his
letter he is Riyaz Leonard almost is
better about apologies apology letter Oh
what did he apologize for what did he
woody woody woody jacked often for yeah
oh he did that's all I could picture him
as his naked body you should read that
because that's a big deal but the
apology letter is like it was a funny or
it's just no it's like I think well he's
very very smart with his words I've yeah
very yes he says stuff that not normally
people can get away with yeah
and it was like one of those apology
letters were there was and it was like
oh she ate the [ __ ] sincere spot yeah no
I'm not
I have no opinion in this whatsoever
sympathize think it's funny that you
need to what I did pretty hilarious not
to the ladies but just if you think
about it like if it was on a TV show be
pretty funny for the lady girl say this
in his letter so basically that's what
happened right so he got in trouble for
that stuff and then he got banned from a
lot and yet a lot of projects coming out
yeah and this happened I mean doesn't
matter realistically you shouldn't have
done it but it happened in like the 90s
and I think early 2000s and in the
letter he addresses the women he did it
to and he even said and there's even one
more that didn't come forward and say
something while he remembers any of them
burn his own yeah he burned himself and
I thought
was actually really burly that's [ __ ]
honorable because that really hooked
audience to be like oh he's big and he's
always been honest if you really think
about even in his comedy I think the
queen shouldn't item he should be Sir
Louis he came from now on the Queen not
from this country
the queen of [ __ ] England sooo
[ __ ] Queen Elizabeth so baby Queen
Latifah is a comedian rapper from the I
know [ __ ] she was our sister
sister back this is that tuberous live
is tia & tamera leti said it so
confidently - yes it makes it fun I need
to stand by it
don't was not his apology letter came
out in November of last year
that's when madama saying he confessed
everything that he did which was
masturbating in front of multiple
comedian women now recently he came made
his comeback he performed at this club
in New York and a lot of people are
upset about it because they're like man
it's too soon
it's don't go to his shows let his fans
go to his shows maybe it's just content
I don't know you know like I understand
like both sides to this it's just
because it's like how come he gets
decide when everybody else is done with
the [ __ ] that he did you know I mean so
he's saying well you guys should be oh
it kind of comes off as when I should
move over it now now it's time for me to
perform and make more yeah yeah so I see
you see how that comes off yeah but at
the same time like I believe that
dollars are power exactly want to
support him you don't go to a show
absolutely because look what happened to
get the Kevin baby toucher
what's his name Lacey Kevin Spacey he
had a movie that came out not too long
ago right guess how much it made an
opening night I was like 600 bucks or
some [ __ ] yeah 625 on opening night I
was over the weekend oh wait no what no
yeah a hundred and twenty-five
they didn't promote it at all because
they don't want to deal with the whole
like even if not that was he couldn't
even get his homie homies to come watch
didn't even show up he's like can you
please show their like I feel like he
didn't even show up a hundred
twenty-five bucks I could go outside
right now and I could beg for that money
I think it was like eight people free
theater or something like that
and who are those mathematically I know
I got this hours the Chinese cooks that
wanted to go to sleep yeah it's not that
movie tickets so they could take a nap
yeah did you go home Louie CK thing is
like kind of similar not the same exact
but the same concept of the Jake Paul
situation of which like I'm not saying
those are the same problems a part
that's low compliance hello good Paul
look and Paul oh it's a different
problem but it's the idea of like people
dead body things oh yeah yeah and people
thought he came back too quick and like
doing one video and then going back to
normal videos and I do understand like
what David said with both sides it's
like from the perspective of like okay I
see this and then he just keeps going
it's like what does he not acknowledge
the fact that he made a huge mistake
however I think it depends more it's
more important for the person to make
the mistake and where it's coming from
media if it's like you're doing it for
yourself and it's like you know it's
actually really hard to come back from
this but if I do there might be that one
person that makes a mistake in life that
sees that even though you make mistakes
you can still get past that and continue
on with what you love to do
yeah right and it's like it also
probably is different with each time and
like how bad the problem is and that's
what I that's what I agree with too it's
just like I think I am a little bit over
people crucifying somebody and not
allowing them to apologize and become a
better person
yeah that's where I have an issue with
it right if in fact that I feel like
he's still a scumbag then yeah let's
just bury him like make sure he never
comes out and once again you could
support them with your dollars but
people have always make mistakes and
people can learn from them too yeah so I
guess it's just a matter of when are you
guys gonna be okay for him to really be
okay to accept those apology I think
people should come back as fast as they
want and you just let people support
with their dollars and
you can come back today if they want to
it louis c.k was a singer this would be
different 100% 100% because Chris Brown
came out with Fame
two weeks after everybody thought yeah
everybody forgot literally Peters girl's
mouth like a fountain he peed in a
girl's mouth no he peed on her she he
peed all over her thing like our Kelly
didn't like singers Kevin there's
something with singers I mean Michael
Jackson had the worst of the worst
claims and that dude is everybody like
beat it without because nothing happened
if I want to be a really bad scumbag
you've got to be a really good scene
gonna balance it out like uh sure - he
did a whole song about how much he
messed up love it
we love it I wish I was that girl yeah
that's what I used to hear I wish he
cheated on me - they're just comics
really split on this some of them so
like this one quote here just writer
wrote that's so weird
if louis c.k had stolen jokes he'd be a
[ __ ] pariah but instead he stole
careers and passion and trust from
possibly brilliant comedians women that
will never get to that we will never get
to hear from and that is worse or it
should be so that's like another thing
that people were looking at it's like
the fact that he exposed themselves to
these potential great women comedians
and then they removed themselves from
that that career like there are no
longer pursue to some people stealing
jokes is worse though and that's not
even true anymore - because Amy Schumer
stole his [ __ ] to meet jokes and she's
perfectly fine now the only case I've
see that happened to was [ __ ] Carlos
Mencia where it ended his career he's
just dumb but I think on another planet
it's because Carlos Mencia chose she
made a decision that is like the
opposite of what Louie CK did which is
I'm done yeah and I think that says more
about the person and also I think with
obviously everybody that has an opinion
towards anything they're talking in the
perspective of how they see the world -
right so it actually it shows a lot of
like whoever's writing it and if it's
negative you kind of know already their
perspective on multiple things
especially because I think if you can't
understand it then I think it shows that
there might be a lack of empathy which i
think is like a key thing but yeah like
do you know Michael Ian Black
like he
I'm saying that he's like we'll take
heed for this but people have to be
allowed to serve their time and move on
with their lives I don't know if it's
been long enough or his career will
recover or if people have him back but
I'm happy to see him try and no one's
saw no one saw the content either of
what if it's like an apology tour or
like what if it's about him going okay
no it's not like it's like that the
content might be you know answering a
lot of this [ __ ] to like people don't
Kevin Hart's had that in his Sena
yeah for the cheating one yeah he
addressed that I don't know it it's I
rather just see the material man I do
the way I see artists and entertainers
it's just a little bit different from
the general public because they're kind
of like our window through the the
experience of life like we look at them
and whatever they experience we want to
we want to see how they express it you
know in a really entertaining way right
it's very different from an average
person who sexually harasses someone and
then just talks about it I think that's
very different not to say that this is
okay in any way but I actually want to
see that like I want to see them go
through this shitty experience and then
talk about that but if we shut that out
and we tell them don't do it at all then
it's like what's the point I actually
want to see him jack off in front of a
girl the consent I want to see all
consenting but they're both adults you
want to watch a porno no I just want to
see like what I want to see his the
faces that he makes like one of my
favorite comedian the faces that he
makes as these jackets forward you
should have just left it I just want to
see Louis CK's face as he jacks off the
end and now you're the [ __ ] weird
wine in the room like explain oh it's
consensual well because that's really
weird I don't understand I just don't
get why he would if I mean this is this
is gonna come out all bad battle means
it to be bad but like if you're gonna if
you're gonna be kind of rapey just be
full rapey you know I mean like I don't
what's it what's the point of being like
just what's it's kind of like that might
be a Spanish it's kind of like people
that that don't full-on rape
by then they like they like to they like
to record girls taking a poop or
something I get you that might be his
thing you know I'm nah something else
that I need to mention here it was the
fact that this comeback of it was a
surprise appearance no one paid money to
go and force it already happened he's I
repeat I an eerie thing can happen
because nobody consented to the Rihanna
to pay for him well he did receive
applause of course he's not all right I
mean it's just you don't stand-ups they
just go up they just show up right
probably like that he showed up at the
Comedy Store
yeah yeah like a 15 minutes uh what is
it that yeah he just showed up and just
went onstage I think there's one witness
did say that she said quote it felt like
he was being thrust upon the audience
without telling them do you remain
anonymous just like the way he trusted
in his [ __ ] wiener one of the other
ladies right he also made jokes about a
rape whistle
and that doesn't you know I think that
is what I can't relate because if I was
sitting in the audience and then he
comes out I wouldn't be like how dare
this [ __ ] but a woman that's
been sexually harassed or whatever can
be can't feel their [ __ ] memories
come back like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
reminds me of that time when this
[ __ ] jacked off them in front of
me to thank [ __ ] this guy I came here to
have a good time not think about a guy I
jacked off in front of me I think at the
perspective people have to realize to
your the power is actually in your hands
you can support him with your dollar
same thing happen with Kevin Spacey
people didn't go see his [ __ ] movie
they didn't promote him you could do
that so actually like him going up on
stage doesn't make a [ __ ] difference
because you could literally not give him
his money and he could disappear but
he's showing usually surprised or dirty
paid either way they could get up and
leave and ask for a refund yeah so
there's a special Eve is a comedy club
and it's open then that's also what you
pay for
yeah and I just don't want people to
feel like they're helpless like you're
not helpless like you really supported
with your dollars or not if you don't
[ __ ] with them get up leave move on you
could ruin his career like that I didn't
know every day a refund at comedy clubs
I'll be like then you heard the joke
already [ __ ]
how do you take the job that joke son I
want better service
[Music]